we're on problem 12.
.1
plus
0.1 squared
0.1 squared plus 0.1 to the third
point 1 to the third so that's the same
thing as 0.1 what's 0.1 squared it's 1
times 1 with two two numbers bought to
the right of the decimal so it's 0.01
and then to the third power you're just
going to end up
one-tenth of that
right 0.01 times 0.1 what's one with
three numbers to the right of the
decimal point if i'm going to add them
all up i get 1 1 1
and that is answer
b they're making sure you can multiply
your decimals
problem 13. if you have trouble with
decimals you might want to get on the
khan academy the actual application it's
free and just uh work through the basic
arithmetic because we have actually a
bunch of things on multiplying decimal
and stuff you have to start at one plus
one but make sure you don't have any
holes in your knowledge it eventually
gets to algebra and trigonometry and
calculus you might find that useful
anyway question 13 a carpenter
constructed a rectangular sandbox with a
capacity of 10
cubic feet
if the carpenter were to make a similar
box
twice as long 2 times length
twice as wide two times width
two times width and twice as high as the
first sandbox what would be the capacity
in cubic feet of the second sandbox so
you might want to visualize it
right the best way to visualize is
probably how many of the old ones could
fit so if this was one of the old ones
right and now i'm going to make a new
one that's twice that's two times is the
size in every dimension right it's two
times the height
so essentially i could let me draw it in
another color so i could increase the
width by two
increase the
depth by 2 or whatever you want to call
it
right
and then i'm going to increase the
height by 2.
and i'm going to have trouble drawing
so how many of the original
sandboxes that's what they want to know
right how many of the original sandboxes
essentially could fit into the new one
well two in one direction times two
times two
so two times two times two is equal to
eight so another way to think of it you
could view the old sandbox as almost a
unit like one cubic unit sandbox and now
we're going to go two in every direction
so we're going to we could fit eight of
the old sand boxes into the new one and
the old one had a capacity of 10 so 8
times that is equal to 80
cubic feet which is choice d
question
14.
these at least so far i think these are
on the easier end they'll probably get
harder but so far they're a lot faster
than the data sufficiency ones which of
the following cannot be a value
of one over
x minus one and i think this is one of
the ones where we have to look at the
choices
one
negative one so can we pick x so this is
negative one well sure if x is equal to
zero one divided by negative one is
negative one so it's not negative one
because that can be a value for that
zero
well this is interesting how can we ever
make this equal to zero
the only the only way we can get this
close to zero is if the denominator
becomes a really huge number right
or but it'll never be equal to zero
it'll just be a really really really
small fraction this approaches zero as x
approaches infinity but this will never
equal 0. so the answer is
b
yeah b i should write a
and b here all of the other things are
completely possible and you just have to
realize that
right yeah we usually see choice b is
like how could this ever equal zero
because the numerator's never equaling
zero
and this can only approach zero if the
denominator gets really really really
big it'll just become a really small
fraction but it'll never
ever equal zero and you could even try
you know one over x minus one
is equal to
zero you can you can try to solve if you
multiply both sides by x minus one you
get one is equal to zero it's impossible
undefined
15
15. a bakery opened yesterday with this
daily supply of 40
dozen
rolls
half of the rolls were sown sold by noon
one half
by noon
and eighty percent of the remaining
rolls were sold between noon and closing
time eighty percent
remaining noon and closing
how many dozen rolls had not been sold
when the bakery closed yesterday okay
half sold by noon so 20 sold
20 sold by noon
and twenty left
right and they said eighty percent of
the remaining sole
roles were sold between noon and closing
time
so we could view it two ways if you want
to do it really fast you're like okay 20
percent of the remaining rolls will not
be sold right so you could say 20
percent
of the remaining rolls
so times 20
don't get sold right if 80 percent gets
sold 20 percent don't get sold and that
equals
what we could say twenty-eight is twenty
times twenty is four hundred two spaces
behind the decimal point and that makes
sense twenty is twenty percent is one
fifth so one fifth of twenty is four
so four roles don't get sold when it
closed you could do the other way around
you could say okay how many sold between
at this time 80 of 20 is 16 more sell
16 cell
and then you can say okay how many total
were sold well 20 plus 16 36 and then 40
minus 36 is also 4. takes a little bit
more time but it gives you the same
answer
eventually time
is what you'll have to focus on once you
are confident you can get every problem
right
what is the combined area in square
inches of the front and back of a
rectangular sheet of paper measuring
eight and a half
by
eleven
so it's essentially going to be two
times eight and a half times eleven
so
right if you just multiply eight and a
half times eleven that would give you
the area of one side so we want the area
of both sides it's going to be two times
that and i wanna do this first so i can
get rid of this mixed number so 8.5
times two that's 17
times 11
which is going to be what 17 times 11 is
170 because that's 17 times 10
plus 17.
so that's 187.
this choice e
choice e
so let's do problem 17.
150 is what percent of 30. so
150
is equal to x
percent
of 30
times 30. or another way we could write
that is
let me just write it as a variable let's
let's figure out as a decimal and then
once you know a decimal it's easy to
convert that into a so 150
is equal to x of 36 or 36x
right this is some number times 36.
divide both sides by 36 you get x is
equal to 150
over
36. let's see i think we can divide the
top and the bottom
definitely we can divide them by 6 right
6 goes into 150
25 times
and it goes into
it goes into 36
six times
right
six oh wait what am i doing it's 30.
my own handwriting got me caught up this
is a much easier problem than what i was
doing they're saying 150 is what is what
percent of 30 right so it's x times 30.
this is easy you mult divide both sides
by 30. i mistakenly wrote 36 there
divide both sides by 30 you get 5 is
equal to x
right
if you wanted to write 5 as a percentage
you just multiply both sides by a
hundred so
you could say x is equal to five hundred
percent
and that makes sense 150 is five times
thirty a hundred percent of thirty is
thirty two hundred percent of thirty is
sixty so forth so 500 of 30 is 150. that
took me too long i think
e
got to make sure your handwriting is
good
next question
18
the ratio two to one third so they're
saying the ratio of two to one third is
equal to
well this is two divided by one third is
equal to two times three over one
which is equal to six over one so two to
one third is the same thing as the ratio
of 6 to 1
which is choice a
right 2 to 1 3 right is equal to 6 to 1.
another way to think about is 2 is 6
times 1 3
and 6 is 6 times 1. same thing so 18 is
a
next question
19.
running at the same constant rate
six identical machines
six identical machines can produce a
total of
270 bottles per minute
270
bottles per minute
at this rate how many bottles could 10
such machines produce in four minutes
okay so how many machines is each how
much does each produce per minute so one
machine produces
one machine
will produce 270 divided by six bottles
per minute
right
that's one machine i just divided both
sides by six six machines produced that
so 10 machines
would produce 10 times as many per
minute so 10 times this is
2700 divided by 6 bottles per minute
and if they want to know how much 10
machines are going to produce in 4
minutes you just multiply this times 4.
so if you say
so this is how much they produce in one
minute so the answer is going to be 2700
times 4
divided by
divided by
6.
so let me see if i can do this math fast
so 6 is equal to 2 times 3
if you divide 27
2700 divided by 3 that's 900
and you get and 3 divided by 3 is 1 and
then 4 divided by 2 is 2 1. so 900 times
2 is equal to 1800
and that is choice
b and i'm all out of time see you in the
next video